Fernando has a good one for us you wake
up one day to find out that your
girlfriend or wife has swapped bodies
with your mom the only way for them to
swap back is for you to have sex with
one of them Greg you seem like you
you're ready to go I think you gotta go
with the wife inside the mom's body
because you you can talk it out like you
can if if you want to keep the girl why
are you laughing so hard if she says go
have sex with the other body I guess
that's that's one thing but I think
she's gonna be like have sex with me in
this body thank you
[Laughter]
for shame Greg for shame but
congratulations Debbie it must be nice
to know that you've raised a good son
and that he loves you and that he would
absolutely have sex with you if you just
told him for a second hey I'm Emma canal
happy Mother's Day